Um,
can we revive the state of
Western civilization using
the new idea that God is
dead?
Well,
it's the wrong question in some sense
because I think it's too diffuse.
To me,
they issue more is do you have problems
in your life that you're not addressing
that you could solve?
And the answer is yes.
And it's an easy thing to figure out.
You sit on your bed one morning and say,
okay,
there's some things that need to be done
that I don't want to do that I could do
that would make things
better by the end of the day.
What are they?
Well,
your,
your conscience will
deliver those suckers,
no time flat map.
And then you might have to say,
okay,
well how do I entice myself
into doing a few of those?
And if you ask,
instead of trying to
force yourself to do it,
like you're a tyrant and
a slave at the same time,
you can usually negotiate with yourself
so that you'll start to sort those
things out,
sort them out,
put your house in order and then move out.
Move on and out.
Yes.
That's a Freudian slip by the way.
Yeah,
so it's important
because the thing is you,
you have a practice domain right there.
There are things that are within
your grasp that you can fix,
fix them and you'll learn.
You'll learn cause it's
harder than it looks.
Fix them and you'll learn how to fix
things and then something else will beckon
as another problem that you could fix.
You know,
you all have your problems.
What does that mean?
Like there's an infinite number
of problems in the world.
Some of them happened to be yours.
Why is that?
I don't know exactly,
but you have your problems.
Great.
Solve them.
You know,
one of the things I
learned as a therapist,
every therapist has to learn this is
because one of the things you wonder when
you're first starting to be a clinician
is how do you not take the catastrophes
of your client's home with you?
And the answer to that is
because it's immoral to,
they're not your problems.
They're their problems like their,
their,
their life.
You all,
your problems are your life.
You don't want to solve someone else's
problems for them because you take away
the,
the deep meaning.
That's to be found in having them work
through the problems on their own.
And then you steal the credit.
Well I can help you with that.
It's like,
well yeah maybe,
but I don't help you with
the next problem then.
So in any case,
you sort of sort out the problems that
are right in front of you and you will,
it will make you grow very,
very rapidly and then you'll be able to
sort out more complex problems without
making them worse.
So,
so you mentioned that through
discussion and dialogue,
we can order the chaos,
the world together,
but do you not think that there
needs to be a higher creator,
an essence of grapes?
Fuck,
it would be possible.
Like how can we each being flawed,
still even working together
create meaning or something good.
Okay.
I,
we don't understand what we are,
we don't understand our own consciousness.
It has a quality of
some sort and it meant,
it manifests itself within us.
It's an orientation towards the good.
That might be one way
of thinking about it.
Freedom to do evil,
but an orientation towards the good.
And so you participate in whatever that
transcendent element of you is while you
try to speak the truth
and sort out the world.
It serves as a guide.
So I know that you're making a,
uh,
a query about some transcendent reality
may be the transcendent reality of God,
but that's the best answer
you're going to get out of me,
okay?
Yes.
Okay.
Two questions.
What's my opinion on the alt right
and what's my opinion on cultural
appropriation?
The idea of cultural appropriation
is absolute nonsense.
That's that [inaudible]
no,
there's no difference between cultural
appropriation and learning from one
another.
They're the same thing.
Now that doesn't mean I can't,
that doesn't mean that there's
no theft between people.
There is,
you know,
and it doesn't mean that just because
you encounter someone else's ideas,
you have an immediate right to those
ideas as if they were your own.
But the idea that manifesting
in your own behavior,
some element of another culture,
the idea that that's
somehow immoral is insane.
It's actually one of the basis of peace.
You know,
one of the things that the various
groups of human beings that exist have to
offer each other is the
tremendous value of their culture.
You know,
it's been really interesting to me,
for example,
to watch the responsive
of wall of everyone.
But for this argument too,
for young Caucasian males to hip hop,
you know,
there's an aggressiveness about hip
hop that's pretty attractive to young
Caucasian males.
And there's something absurd about,
about the,
the,
the spectacle of the young Caucasian
males taking on the persona of inner city
black gang members,
you know,
but,
but I'm sympathetic to it because
there's an aggressiveness to that,
to that art form that's a necessary
corrective to the insistence that the
highest moral virtue for a
modern man is harmlessness,
which is absurd.
Women don't even like cardless man,
they hate them.
They liked that
park.
Women
want are dangerous men who are civilized
and they want to help civilize them.
That's beauty and the beast.
So,
you know,
I'll tell you a funny story and only
engineers could have come up with this
because they are the only ones that have
the unparalleled blindness to social
convention that would
allow them to discover it.
So the Google engineers,
I like engineers by the way,
cause they're very straightforward.
The Google engineers wrote a book awhile
back called a billion wicked thoughts,
which was a study of Internet searches,
billions of them literally.
And they were looking a
lot at pornography use.
And while there's lots of known
about male pornography use,
partly and it's easy to understand,
I mean males are pretty visually oriented
and what attracts them to pornography
is fairly straight forward.
Um,
you can tell that if you look at
graffiti and a men's washroom,
you know,
it's like two circles and a triangle
and the men are absolutely transfixed.
Bye
[inaudible].
So
for women,
his story is more complex.
They use pornography too.
But it tends to be literary because women
tend to like words more than they like
visual stimuli.
And so the Google guys tried to track
down the architectural structure of all,
they didn't use those words
of female pornography use.
And so some of you know how many of
you know what a Harlequin romance is.
Okay,
good.
So those are archetypal stories,
right?
That's the taming of the wild man,
essentially by the,
by the desirable in virgin a woman.
And if you think women don't want that,
then you better bloody well come up with
an explanation for 50 shades of grey,
right?
Which is the most,
the most rapid selling novel in human
history and merged at exactly the same
time that all of this noise about the
lack of the absence of gender roles is,
is being produced.
You know,
on mosques.
It's like perfect female fantasy.
It's exactly Arkan typically correct.
It's beauty and the beast.
So what the Google guys showed was
the structure of beauty and the beast,
although they didn't use that as a
reference that the female pornographic
fantasy was wild guy.
Um,
you know,
somewhat careless about the
wants and desires of others,
attractive to everyone.
Therefore High Status Tamed by the Magic
of a single woman and brought into a
relationship with her.
Okay,
so,
but here's the comical part.
This just made me laugh,
man.
It was like,
why were the five categories
of most desirable male
entity used most broadly and
female pornography?
Oh,
it's so embarrassing.
Women,
you have to cover your head.
Well,
I say this because vampire,
we're both billionaire surgeon and pirate.
All
right.
Another question.